another brexit showdown between britain
and the european union british prime
minister boris johnson
saying the uk will pull out of talks
aimed at striking a free trade deal
between the block
if there's no agreement by october 15th
in a statement statement released to the
press johnson said
there needs to be an agreement with our
european friends by the time
of the european council on the 15th of
october
if it's going to be enforced by the end
of the year
if we can't agree by then that i do not
see that there will be
afraid a free trade agreement between us
and
we should both accept that and move on
britain formally left the eu in january
but
a transition period was agreed until the
end of
the year well for more on that i'm
joined
from brussels by our correspondent georg
matas and from london
by birkett musk good morning to you both
berget let's start with you
we've got boris johnson delivering an
ultimatum
and the financial times saying the uk is
planning to override
parts of the brexit withdrawal agreement
what is going on here
well there's quite a lot of movement
here in london when it comes to
a new push for the brexit talks and one
is as you said this new ultimatum
but potentially more controversial is
the so-called internal
market bill and this is a new
legislation that the uk is expected
to start on wednesday and
from what we know now parts of this uk
legislation would be in contravening the
withdrawal agreement that the uk and the
eu
had agreed on when they uh finished
their brexit talks so that was
the just the divorce agreement how the
matter how the uk
would leave the european union and this
is an international law
so this has got some alarm bells ringing
here in london
experts and also critics of the
government are saying well if
the uk wants to be this new and so
self-confident global britain
it needs to be trusted and it can't go
back on any international agreements
that it has with the european union with
its biggest trading partner
so quite a bombshell announcement and an
interesting weekend uh to come in
london and when it comes to the uk eu
talks
well alarm bells must be ringing in
brussels too if
london rips up the withdrawal deer deal
gail
what would that mean for relations
between the uk and brussels
terry over this four year brexit saga
we've seen many setbacks
bergen and i have seen them and as she
points out this one is a real bombshell
not only because
the uk backtracks on internationally
agreed documents
but more importantly the
northern ireland part of the withdrawal
agreement has specifically been
written up in order to avoid northern
ireland becoming a bargaining
chip in order to avoid a situation where
where conflict
could arise again over that uh region
and
that is the situation we find ourselves
now in and the eu keeps wondering
or people here in brussels keep
wondering why have we been talking
if the uk now threatens to withdraw from
something we have been
we have agreed well indeed let's talk a
little about northern ireland
should the uk goes back on its
agreements with brussels that
could have ramifications for that border
between northern ireland and the
republic of ireland
irish foreign minister simon coveny uh
has been
tweeting saying this would be a very
unwise way
to proceed uh you can sense the sort of
underlying frustration there georg
remind us what's at stake here regarding
that border
oh a lot of is at stake look a number of
things in the
whole brexit problem you could resolve
with some low-key
deals but what you cannot resolve is the
fact
that northern ireland and the republic
of ireland have a common border and this
is an open border on the island of
ireland
now northern ireland belonging to the uk
and ireland the republic of ireland
belonging to the eu and that open border
is of course a threat to the internal
market
that something that is economically very
dear is at the heart of the
eu construct on top of this you have a a
political conflict
between those two entities on the island
of ireland and the big concern of the eu
but of many people on the island of
ireland of course is that this
political conflict was had which has
caused many people
dying could come up again if
indeed this common border would be under
threat and if the uk drops out this
would be the case
if the uk does scrap the withdrawal
agreement with the eu
how's this likely to go down with the
british public
well boris johnson was elected on the
ticket of that brexit deal
is easy oven ready is what he said and
this is
what uh why the british public voted for
him he was sort of optimistic and
fresh-faced and they
wanted uh either they wanted a solution
for brexit so that he now says
well actually we have no deal with all
the economic consequences that this
brings
mostly for the uk that will make some
people wonder
what did he really mean when he said
that the brexit deal would be very very
easy
people will be wondering um whether you
know he was telling the truth at that
time what has changed in half a year
when he said it was going to be so so
easy and now it's just
not bigger mass in london and georg
matas in brussels thank you very much to
you both
well as you've just heard from our
london correspondent lots of uncertainty
in the uk as negotiators work on a
withdrawal deal
she sent us uh berget mass sent us this
report on british
businesses who trade with the eu many
are worried that they'll be forced to
compromise on prices and products that
keep their customers coming back
whoever shops at borrow market in south
london is looking for the best
quality tasty treats from across europe
blueberries dominic koitzel scouted
cheese from the netherlands
dairy co-operatives in france deliver
comptia and moppie
in the summer there's feta cheese from
the greek island of lesbos
but brexit poses a threat to its little
cheese paradise
a massive worry the i mean it has been
worried since the referendum
and already we were on our third
stockpiling plan
um to make sure we got enough stock at
the prices that we're currently paying
and we don't have to incur any higher
prices that might be
introduced by higher terrorists koid
shows us his storeroom
he's worried that the already pricey
cheese he sells will be slept with high
tariffs
that's assuming it can even be delivered
undamaged
with new border checks goods could be
held up for days
the transport logistics is going to be
that much more complicated
it's going to be expensive because it
could be extra paperwork involved
and i can only imagine it's not going to
be as free-flowing as it is currently
food experts warn that the supply chains
of fresh products could be disrupted
britain imports roughly 80 percent of
its fruit alone
merchants also have another worry if
there is no trade deal with brussels
the u.s might fill the gap food products
could even become cheaper
but what about quality american health
and environmental standards are lower
for example when it comes to meat
i think the real worry is that if we get
these influx of
uh much cheaper food being imported that
actually
supermarkets um will opt to stock those
uh chain restaurants may opt to stock
those and so our traders here
who you know will only supply the best
food
at a fair price means that the disparity
between
what consumers are offered is going to
be much wider than it already is
cheese merch and dominic has had lots of
discussions about brexit
including with max tucker the fishmonger
i believe england will always be okay
always call me old-fashioned this any
other
we won world wars in this tiny little
island you know
there is other countries that deal with
us other than europe
coit is preparing himself in his own way
a friend of his makes
cheddar at a pinch maybe he'll end up
selling this kind of cheese